welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 7 episode one how poopy got
his poop back a profoundly titled
episode but AA to How Stella Got Her
Groove Back it's a solid season premiere
I got to say great jokes awesome
callbacks clever animation bits Easter
eggs and a full tribute to Hugh Jackman
in his career I am going to break down a
ton of details that you might have
missed in this episode okay this season
Now features Ian Cardone as Rick Sanchez
and Harry Beldon as Morty Smith and I
really got a hand to them and to the
casting team because I got to admit I
often forgot while watching this that
these were new actors voicing the parts
I at least found the transition to be
pretty steamless aside for a few moments
but I think a lot of that is really in
our mind and I'm going to break down why
you're welcome to disagree with me this
is just really my take on why we should
just be okay with this the episode opens
with the Smith family including space
Beth that's Beth clone who returned as
regular in season 6 they complain about
their house guest Mr Poopy butthole and
Jerry complains that he's messing with
his too it's an antique the buttons are
fragile I just love the idea that the
family has an interdimensional cable box
but despite having that technology
Jerry's still using too technology that
really hasn't been a relevant service in
the past like 5 to 10 years but I guess
he just doesn't know how to work the
interdimensional cable or isn't allowed
to use it a drug dealer hits him up for
cash yeah I prefer the term pharmacist
so do they solid burn from Beth about
pharmacists who have had a mixed track
record in this country for
overprescribing opioids to addicts watch
dop sick it'll make you really sad but
it's a very important thing to watch and
this might be something better might be
particularly sore over as a healthcare
provider at least to horses who has
watched her father suffer from addiction
Mr Poopy butthole is in rough shape we
last saw him in the season six finale
the Stinger scene looking jacked as he
told us that he was rebounding from his
divorce from Amy by getting fit and then
promply breaking his legs by squatting
too much weight now he's completely
relapsed in the corner we see custody
law for dummies and when we see a pulled
back shot of that cover later it has
white figures tug Waring over a child so
sad and exactly what Mr booby but hole
will do with his kid later this episode
his bathrobe is monogrammed M I thought
it was for Mr booy but hole his first
name is Wayne though so maybe this is
Morty's bathrobe he says but you didn't
expect to see me in a cold open H yeah a
bit of a meta nod to the voice cast
switches John Allen now voices Mr Poopy
butth hole and I think a lot of people
might have been surprised to see yet
another royland voice character show up
here Mr Poopy but hole references when
Beth shot him back in season 2's total
rickall episode and he finds a new
bottle of booze and you can see the
frames on the wall in the background are
ES one of them is cracked presumably
from when he chucked a bottle at the
wall after an opening title sequence
that probably has some episodes that
we're never going to see like there's
one where the dance off between Beth and
space Beth in a dessert themed Kingdom
and another where Rick and Morty are
skiing snowboarding on their own tongues
and I like how the movement of the
skiing and snowboarding is different
when Rick has a PSE and Morty doesn't
the swerving is exactly the way you
Center your gravity on whether you're
skiing or snowboarding anyway back to
the episode Rick continues his search
for Rick Prime that's his white whale
his nemesis who killed his wife and
daughter and to mention c137 he spent
much of season six hunting this guy down
but he left Morty behind with a robot
version of himself in the second half of
that season on the screen we see the
yellow Central finite curve that's a
spiral display of the Multiverse that
was first shown in the season 5 finale
Rick Moray Jack Rick's sarcastically
says that Morty just missed his Showdown
with Rick Prime he's calling it a big
sword fight at top the Hoover Dam he
fell and landed on a sharp Spike and
then whispered thank you like a werewolf
I was asking to be polite I'm not sure
but there seems to be a reference to the
1992 film universal Soldier which has a
sequence in the Hoover Dam and ends with
jeanclaude vanam impaling Dolph lungrin
on spikes but there's no respectful
werewolf Style thank you now this is
just from my hearing but Harry Beldon is
a seamless Morty but Ian Cardone seems
to be wavering a bit as Rick but I
actually think it's totally fine it just
sounds like that to us and if you
compare his Rick to Justin ryland's
voice in season 1 and season 2 he sounds
a lot more like the original core of the
character it's just that we the viewers
began to hear Rick in recent years as an
increasingly grumbly royland who would
sometimes drink in the ADR Booth I
actually highly recommend you read Scott
martyr and Dan harman's Interview With
The Hollywood Reporter about their
casting process apparently thousands of
candidates were narrowed down to
hundreds and Ian Cardone was actually
one of the first they heard and marked
as having flashes of Rick apparently the
names of the applicants were completely
hidden from Harmon and he said quote
your ears very quickly get so confused
when you're trying to tell the
difference between a 9.5 and 9.7 on a
does this sound like my friend scale
it's a fascinating article again please
read it so quick solution for Mr Poopy
butool is to scare him away with a robo
ghost he first creates a sentient robot
and uploads business but unplugs it at
77% so that it'll be unfinished business
but then after killing it the ghost
drops through the
floor okay I need to make gravity part
of its finished business and leave
floors unfinished it kind of reminds me
of when Morty dropped the lightsaber
directly through the floor in the season
six finale would this ghost just keep
going further and further down to the
core of the planet so Rick calls out the
intervention format as something that he
says has a 10% success rate ComEd I Al
and clinically in his eyes referring to
real world interventions 10% sounds a
bit low there but he's also referring to
when interventions have been used as a
comedic premise in sitcoms and I kind of
feel like this is Dan Harmon speaking
from the writer room as many TV shows
have had an intervention episode but if
you think about it Dan Haron shows like
community and rck and Morty typically
stage intervention s conversations and
more active context so that's it's
really characters confronting each
other's behavior in the pursuit of
something else and that's what this
episode does it's not characters all
sitting around in a circle it's
characters actively doing something and
having that meaning ful conversation in
the pursuit of that mission Beth
mentions The Ghost and not with a
ghost oo that that's interesting you
kind of gave him a little power by
mentioning him there's a lot of science
to unpack about ghosts yeah this seems
to adhere both to the afterlife concept
of people having second lives so long as
people keep them in their memories but
also the Beetlejuice rule where if you
mentioned his name three times he
appears this is something Dan Harman
played with in my favorite gag from the
series Community maybe your study buds
will go what's the blonde's name bitter
butter Beetle Juice ginifer must be be
real special don't you usually wear the
stripey turquoise Beetle Juice
numbers there's nothing in your playlist
but spooky party the Beetle Juice
soundtrack and NPR Podcast so Rick puts
a crew together for Mr Poopy butth
hole's intervention including Gearhead
AKA revolio clockberg Jr who has a rack
and pinions pinup poster next squanchy
Squan told you he wasn't dead we
squanching yeah Squan has made several
cameos over the years like in memories
and in flashbacks since his supposed
death and the wedding squater episode
but apparently this either being retcon
or is being pulled from Another Universe
each time they recruit a new intervenor
for this they respond with a you son of
a type response like in the heist
episode season 4 episode 3 W crew over
kwu Morty by the way if you're
interested in my breakdown of that
episode I did break down all of season 4
on this channel you can go find that
next we visit the home of bird person
where we see his daughter with Tammy
bird daughter messing with her phone on
the couch and there's a jacket with what
looks like various rebellious patches
anti- Federation stuff there's also a
magazine beak talk and then some frames
on the wall of several images of bird
person with Rick as well as the band
they had with squanchy the flesh
curtains this video is sponsored by
Dungeon Hunter 6 the newest game in the
Dungeon Hunter franchise Dungeon Hunter
6 is a free-to-play mobile fantasy arpg
with a fast-paced hack and SL combat it
rules it's absolutely free to play
download it now using the link in the
description or scan the QR code on
screen if you're viewing on a PC Dungeon
Hunter 6 makes it super fun to tweak
your build in skills get your characters
buff up and you can beat up Big Bad
Bosses but in Dungeon Hunter 6 killing
AOSS boss just ramps things up after you
kill a boss you can ride them around
summon them in a battle perform combo
skills and eventually even shape shift
into them with over 100 unique bosses to
conquer plus new classes and units
updated monthly the possibilities are
endless the skill animations are awesome
and combat is super fluid in a way I
genuinely did not expect for a mobile
game plus it's super fun to play with
friends you build a guild battle in real
time Guild Wars and trade items with the
in-game auction system download Dungeon
Hunter 6 now for free on both Android
and iOS by clicking the link in the
description or scan the QR code if
you're on a PC using our link will give
you a starter pack worth $50 including
10 summoning Scrolls an accessory pack
and a demonic wolf SSR Lieutenant once
you've got an account enter Lucky Spin
event for free to win great prizes like
iPhone 15 Pro Max PS5 Apple watch and
more starting October 13th bird person
says that he found a severed grite arm
and her Federation hit list so it just
seems like bird daughter Rebels both
against her father and her mother Tammy
with the Federation and bird person says
that she was imprisoned in a fatal
training camp and I don't know what that
means but it sounds crazy so the next
recruit is a Smith's long TI neighbor
Jean who's mowing his grass but his Ry
lawn mower just keeps going on and on
and kind of becomes a maximum overdrive
scenario where the machines come to life
it pushes a parked car into the street
so it violently kills this motorcyclist
and we'll next see it in the post credit
scene we'll talk about that later so
they take Mr Poopy butthole to a
restaurant called the use inside the bar
stools are butts with heart tattoos and
slap marks on the cheeks Over the Bar it
reads the first is free a neon sign
reads copyright proof beers so you know
the animators wouldn't have to pay
licensing fees a banner reads you puke
we laugh there's another Banner with
someone just puking there's a sign that
says no black light allowed gross Mr
Poopy butth hole says that he hired a
predator as a pi referring to the yaa
race from the Predator franchise we see
the app on his phone it's like an old
geoc city style website design with last
update 2001 Mr poy butthole reveals this
is a great place to celebrate my
birthday birthday birthday birthday
birthday birthday birthday now I hate to
pull a Simpson dead at because I'm sure
the writers of Rick and Morty are well
aware of this more than anyone is and
they probably do this intentionally but
this is an amazing Simpsons gag I hope
we'll always be together together
together together but Rick decides to
get Ricky Ricky wrecked leading to a
montage set to this SCA sound the lyrics
come at us really fast but they're
really fun so I'm going to spell them
out for you here I take a shot do a pop
blow a line Huff turpentine Get Wrecked
text your ex fight a cop feeling fine
punch your dick turn some tricks quit
your job buy a dog have two beers then T
more pop a pill and meet the floor when
Rick opens the portal on the street I
just love that Jean does a cannonball
into it and then they go to the strip
club where an octopus and a police
officer hat spanks Mr Po butthole they
do shots of an alien with five belly
buttons but if you count there are only
five there's one for Mr Po butthole one
for squashy one for Rick one for bird
person one for Gearhead and then not
another one for G so yeah he really is
drinking out of something else then they
go to a universe where everyone is a
bottle or a can so they basically drink
their innards which is horrifying then
they party in the cement mixer party
truck with a sloshing liquor in it Jean
asks for a toilet and there actually is
one but there is a sign over it for
bidding pooping in it many people have
tried that before I guess but then when
it rotates all the piss dumps into the
booze which is just so gross because it
means most of this liquor is probably
pee then they go to a club where honey
drips on Rick which is a reference to
the 1998 blade film where blood drips on
the clubber before it just sprays down
from the nozzles this is a bee Club it's
not another planet though it's just just
the normal universe and here they meet
Hugh Jackman and Jackman actually voices
himself for this episode which is crazy
Rick says makes sense he recognizes me
we've both hosted the Oscars this is a
reference to how Dan Haron and Rob shr
are in contact with Hugh Jackman I'm
thinking they both were on the writing
team when Hugh Jackman hosted the Oscars
in 2009 they were part of the group that
came up with all the bits for the
opening monologue and a musical number
which I will always remember because it
has this amazing joke for Hugh Jackman's
doing like a musical bit about the
reader I never read the reader and he's
just wearing these like silver jumpsuits
because he has no idea what the reader's
about and Rob TR and Dan Haron actually
nominated for Emy for their writing for
that here we see Hugh Jackman wearing a
white tank and jeans which is his common
Wolverine attire his belt buckle has
three claw marks of course for the
Wolverine scratches turns out Hugh
actually knows Jean because he married
his cousin meaning Jean's cousin must be
debor Lee furnus whom Hugh Jackman was
married to from 1996 to this year they
actually just got separated this past
September the Jack Shack is actually
full of nods to Hugh Jackman's films
there's the Jackman poster with Hugh
Jackman as all the different X-Men not
the other actors in the X-Men movie
nearby one actually reads Le Jackman for
Hugh Jackman's role in the 2012 lay
Miser Rob film there's also a nude
portrait of Hugh Jackman with his
Wolverine claws out if you look closely
the beer on the table are all huge
Jackman Brands like Jackman something
and it's like an Australian label
there's Hughes pale ale there's also we
later see the Rick and Morty classic
foies brand of beer bird person does the
knife through the fingers trick that
Bishop does an aliens Hugh has a trophy
case that includes a fist with three
Wolverine claws and then frames over it
include a marriage photo that I assume
is with de Lee furnace there's a TV
Awards photo with the rock there's also
a framed photo of Hugh with his real
life dog algra an exact Recreation of
this photo but here in animation they
made algra look like a brown version of
Snuffles AKA snowball Morty's past dog
from season 1 H calls the statuette a
Tony Award but really the Tony statuette
is actually a disc that shows the comedy
and drama masks it's not like the masks
separated like this but Hugh Jackman did
win a Tony in 2004 For The Boy From Oz
and an honorary Tony in 2012 few claims
that that he not Billy Ocean wrote the
song Caribbean Queen Mr Bo butthole asks
does wolverin hurt a little every time
every time a referenced line in X-Men
when Wolverine told Rogue that his claws
hurt every time Jean says Amy's coming
back Dead or Alive no to RoboCop's catch
phrase dead or alive you're coming with
me now maybe it's an animation flaw here
but in this shot San's leg is a rounded
off stump disconnected from his foot but
I do love the continuity with a gash
still in his paw actually from here on
in the episode you'll notice it is
bandaged Beck Bennett voices the robo
poost Nick Rutherford wrote this episode
and Nick Rutherford Beck Bennett Kyle
Mooney and Dave mccy were all part of a
sketch group called Good Neighbor Jean
and Hugh reenact they say anything
stereo bit with Hugh Jackman singing the
lyrics to Billy oceans Caribbean Queen
but Amy's levitating is actually the
result of the Predator Pi cradling her
so Mr poy but hole kidnaps his son and
Rick recommends doing the mud thing and
not to Schwarzenegger cloaking himself
in mud and Predator to hide the Predator
uses his three-point laser sight to
track them he really has all of his
familiar gear the retractable spear the
razor sharp net squ he pulls out his
tooth to drink a growth formula like he
does in wedding squanchers but he throws
up from all the crap they've been
consuming the Predator stuffs Gearheads
nuts into his
mouth why is this my thing this is a
call back to season 2 episode two Morty
night run when Rick does the same move
to him Mr Po butle reference in season 4
episode 3 which was the heist episode
one crew over the crew crew Morty which
shows Mr poy butthole beating the crap
out of all the students in his class
they end up dog piling on the predator
and Mr Poopy but hole is like give me
that big old tooth Rick meanwhile wants
his skull since the predator collects
skull trophies from its victims but
they're able to make peace and the
Predator gives Mr Poopy but hole a
musket but Hugh Jackman returns and
knocks him out with a Grammy statuette
the Grammy is for Caribbean Queen
written by Hugh Jackman h16 which feels
like a totally fake Grammy that he or
his new agent may be made for himself to
justify his stupid lie to himself and
for whatever reason Hugh Jackman covered
himself in mud naked his crotch region
is blurred out so they eat at Taco
tambourine and bird person's phone alert
is two Eagle
cries bird person tells Rick it was
canonical to see him probably notd to
this bird person's appearance as a
solidly Canon episode with repercussions
for future events cuz you know that's
not always the case when these
characters appear the episode shifts
into Mr Poopy but hole's voice over as
each of them fade away a reference to
the epilogue sequence of The Sandlot of
all movies to reference in which the
narrator references everyone's features
as they dissolve out of the shot Mr
Poopy but hole says Hugh went home to
glue together the Tony award that they
had broken which reminds me of the
epilog and my favorite episode of the
office when Jan has to glue together
Michael Scott's dundy award after she
had broken it and Mr poy butle says also
to put a bullet in all future Wolverine
references thanks to us because yeah now
any future Rick and Mory reference to
Wolverine is going to be contextualized
by what happened in this episode Rick
reveals that these Fades are actually
the result of fading pills and he gets
ahead of all the social media um excuse
me by saying that Gearheads taxi fading
was caused by the pill thinking that the
taxi was his Overcoat so the episode's
post credit scene catches up with the
ridy lawn mower in a smalltown sheriff
committed to bringing it town the cin
Marquee has what I think are my favorite
references this episode the movies that
were playing at this theater were Jan
quadrant Vincent 16 that's from the
interdimensional cable 2 episode that
was an improvised movie title from
royland starring Jan Michael Vincent and
he just swapped out Michael for Quadrant
so it's Jan quadrant Vincent 16 the
other movie looks like it was two
brothers tomato monster of course the
two brothers movie from the first
interdimensional cable episode Ricky
minutes the sheriff stalls by kissing
his Celtic cross his locket his Clover
repentant his Bible with a bullet in it
and then he sings this song these lyrics
are actually from a real Irish ballad
called the of donle but the lawnmower
just runs him over and in the bloody
mess we see all these Ford good luck
charms along with a button for Guinness
we record's most superstitious man that
is a lot of Easter eggs in this episode
with nods to Wolverine Community
Simpsons Hugh Jackman's Oscar monologue
Predator blade aliens The Sandlot I feel
like this episode was made for me so I
just really loved and appreciated
breaking it down and hopefully we'll be
able to keep doing these this season all
of the episodes of Rick and Morty season
6 were broken down for us by Whitney van
laningham who did an incredible job and
now she's breaking down new episodes on
her channel Whitney Vision so please
subscribe and watch her videos there
please subscribe to new rock stars like
this video and comment down below with
your favorite part of this episode and
your general thoughts on where this
season's going and I'll see you next
time bye
everybody